even for the sitcom side they were
looking for compelling stories your
story very compelling we'd overall into
that first interview but has anybody
approached you about want to turn that
into a sitcom or anything yeah but
that's not what I want to do I don't
wanna put out another prison sitcom or
anything about anything about that what
I'm gonna do is gonna be responsible and
that's not responsible you know the
orange is new black and Oz and I don't
like they can have all that that's not
they can they can live in those
fictitious prison stories I'm you know
lock up is doing a good job of telling
that story so is that what people
approached you about it's like okay we
have a vision Ollie you're in prison is
that what they said what they go that's
what they don't approach me about it if
that's the work they've seen you do they
haven't you know they think they that's
what you gonna say long but I don't have
a gimmick for them so that's the thing
I'm writing about what I want to sow in
a that's thing when it's not my goal
it's no pressure on me hmm that's other
people want me to write secon that's
what other people think success is
that's not what I think success is
because I'm a stand-up I didn't go to
Julliard to be an actor I didn't go to
the writing school I want our own home
my skills and my craft being a stand-up
and not a talk-show host
I'm not a gimmick writer I'm not a
dancer I'm not a rapper I'm not nothing
that I am a comic and I'm cool with that
maybe maybe I say a old way of thinking
but I know people who I don't know a lot
of doctors who trying to do any other
thing other than be a doctor yeah I
don't know any lawyers who you know
trying to be something else I think you
know it's certain craft if he will have
to be what they are if you need butchers
I don't want my butcher you know wanting
to be an actor and then I can't you know
somebody gotta actually want to be a
butcher
so I'm just a stand-up is it so what are
your goals would stand up then what you
mean with my goals off well you said the
TV stuff I wasn't your goal I've
accomplished every goal that stand up
really but what what more is for me what
is there for me to do other than keep
doing specials
yeah I'm specials because how many
people how many people get specials in
in a comedy career very rare I mean more
getting them on Netflix I guess Netflix
hard to pump them out but Netflix is not
Comedy Central mm-hmm that's the
regardless of what people try to all you
go to nestle there if you go to Netflix
when you're trying to get some fact you
can record your own next expression and
sell it to him how about that but
comment section you can't do that I
reckon somebody put the money into me to
shoot my thing to know this is the home
that is in the title Comedy Central the
central location for comedy
next is HBO then I'll do a Showtime then
we get around to doing a Netflix as
that's important to me at that time but
other than that I'm just keep pumping
down specials because I don't think
nobody ever asked Richard Pryor when he
was doing albums a red fox when they're
doing albums on what you want to do next
do what I want to do mm-hmm
they do whatever they wanna do and I'm
one of the people who held bet on
letting people understand that you don't
have to do you don't have to be nothing
else to be considered a successful comic
that's a bunch of [__] to me I want
to be able to become an actor or
something else if you consider a
successful comic what type of [__] is
that
so I guess football player has got to do
something else can to go to the Hall of
Fame in football so you got to do
something else what you got to do yeah
that to get the Basketball Hall of Fame
what do you got to do that place don't
know that the basketball you got to play
cricket - what you got to do so in a
comedy
why do I have to become an actor or
being a movie internship to because
there's a good stand-up it's just
bringing a new awareness to you get new
new fans if you're more if you're in
more than one place that's the finding
but what does that have to do with stand
out though they can lead to bigger
venues more more so why do you have to
do the I do you understand what I'm
saying why do you have to do something
else to be considered a good stand-up
well if you're just a stand-up they can
only see you where they just a stand-up
that's what you [__] do you are a
stand-up I love stand-up I know but I'm
asking why doesn't stand-up comic have
to do something else other than be a
stand-up comic to be famous for being a
stand-up comic it's just the more
awareness the more you do the more
people can see you why people not away
good but you're not doing stand-up when
they getting to where you act it you say
something else is worth it's not [__]
stand-up but people say they'll start a
podcast about what people's they got to
do what the truth is I mean other comics
will do TV shows or other podcasts to
then drive new fans to then see them do
stand-up you know how [__] stupid
that sound I mean I just do stand-up I'm
not on a TV show
or anything else but I'm just thinking
of what are the most a Venusian attract
new fans to then come see my stand-up
and see me live so instead of me maybe
doing a one-nighter somewhere I can then
sell out a weekend at a club or sell out
at a theater it though all the vehicle
is to drive stand up but there's
multiple ways to do it
beyond just stand up I guarantee you
you're doing a sitcom you'll [__]
stand ups up hmm I [__] guarantee it
I've seen that too I've seen it a
thousand times
yeah I've seen that too yeah the people
who was good at stand-up trying to do
other [__] and in a [__] stand-up
selves so then you're being you're
taking away from what you're supposed to
be in order to do some others
to get other fans to come see you
[__] suck and what you're supposed to
be yeah just like people the internet
the internet [__] are not good
at stand-up live that's why they don't
[__] show they standard that's why it
doesn't make sense to me to try to bait
followers but not [__] work your PIN
and work your crap it's too [__]
different things you doing sketches and
make it take cut action this [__]
ain't nothing like me doing a live show
you it's no comparison it's no
comparison yeah you're scaring me a
little bit
the obvious thing the understanding is
so [__] up that comics have been brain
[__] to think that you have to do other
[__] and your stand-up is not important
when that's what you're supposed to be
and let everything let that drive
everything just with the priced and that
was so strong that his first
[__] movie was about his
stand-up his life jo Jo dancer that was
his first movie first movie whoa I did
not know that
wow that's impressive that's how good is
[__] stand-up was yeah and I think
people have lost sight of his stand that
was so superior that the rest of the
[__] came he never abandoned his
stand-up people trying to woman try to
get here to go there to did come I get
none is the only [__] work like that